you're gonna kick of birth it's dopin
amazing about the history of cultural
appropriation but I could use the
distance to make my case
holy cow it's MC serch from third base
appropriation happens when unpress
cultures gets co-opted by a dominant
other so settle back for this quick
recap by two white dudes in a rap okay
let's begin way back in the days al
jolson say till he was black in the face
saint came a guy who's more in desert
than anyone before him elevates
presently and I kind of appropriating he
was the king that's actually short for
taking suddenly catching rock and roll
mr. Rolling Stones and the Beatles stole
share dressed up in a room where Kenny
gene that smooth jazz oh hell yeah then
all the white rappers came to the game
Saints were walking walk the Beasties in
how to paint and snow would inform on
anyone missing stop appropriate and
listen I can't help but notice that
someone is missing what about the
appropriators third base
still got my ghetto path so made me give
you the gas face raps Justin and Jimmy
sublime Macklemore and worst of all eggy
the Washington Redskins Madonna Kabbalah
Coachella hipsters guzzling ayahuasca
cornrows rust by Kardashian degenerate
and Rachel Dolezal of a I remember Miley
Cyrus and tell us what's working white
guys saving jazz and Louisville and not
working and now it's all meta info is
back skateboard kids used to dress like
rappers but now you got rapid dressing
like skate it's multiple layers of
cultural appropriators cultural
appropriation cultural appropriation but
are you sure we're cool to do this I
produce nomadic I'm good you
[Music]